let's look at the some details of the
indictment here pulling it up right now
the first 31 counts counts 1 through 31
are willful for Violet for willful
retention of National Defense
information so that's actually holding
on to the documents the remaining
charges are basically some form of
obstruction or lying to investigators he
had six top secret documents which is
the highest level of classification than
in the storage room he had 11 top secret
36 secret 28 confidential documents
according to the indictment just some
examples I have highlighted of the types
of documents and intelligence briefing
related to military activities and
planning of foreign countries another
one concerning nuclear capabilities of a
foreign country and then this is these
are some pictures that have floated
around the internet of how these
documents were being stored on a kind of
stage in Mar-A-Lago there's a bunch
crammed into a bathroom
and then there's a bunch of newspapers
clippings mixed in with redacted
documents on the floor this picture to
me is that it shows the degree to which
it was like a bunch of his personal
stuff just mixed together with
classified documents kind of opening the
door for then the FBI to come in and
sift through all of this stuff to look
for classified documents you know you
get me one hoarder on that jury and
Trump is going to walk yeah what uh do
these pictures and this evidence say to
you Clark about the kind of strength of
the case against Trump
well um it's horrifying it's horrifying
so two things are true uh we do have a
problem with overclassification no
serious person disputes that but that
doesn't mean that every document that
has been classified
um was improperly classified plenty of
documents that the US government
produces the disclosure of which would
would result in the loss of human lives
it would result in people being killed
who are working for our intelligence
agencies in hostile countries to Simply
wave your hands at this and say well you
know everybody does it and therefore
Trump should get a free pass uh I think
is untenable what everyone brings up as
an analogy is Hillary Clinton is what
Hillary Hillary Clinton did the same or
worse or not as bad as what Trump did
let's take a quick look back at what
Comey had to say at that famous press
conference where he uh dropped the
charges and then dig into that question
a little bit more deeply although we did
not find
colleagues in
the violate law
of classified information
there is evidence that they were
extremely careless although there is
evidence of potential violations of the
statutes regarding the handling of
classified information
our judgment is that no reasonable
prosecutor would bring such a case
should she have been handed a free pass
uh or you know should Trump because she
was kind of handed a free pass also be
handed a free pass
well let's be clear what Hillary did was
jaw-droppingly irresponsible and
criminal
um if you are housing if you are the
Secretary of State and you are housing
emails on an unsecured Betty Crocker
Easy-Bake server at your home which she
was you might as well set up every email
that comes into that server to forward
to Putin and Xi Jinping and Kim Jong-un
because they're going to be reading them
uh and um so so the level of
irresponsibility and cynicism on her
part and criminality uh is difficult to
express everything you just saw from
Comey there is a is a you know sort of a
retcon or a retroactive attempt to
rationalize the pre-ordained conclusion
that Hillary Clinton would be let off
the hook and that was preordained she
went about obstructing justice in a way
that's that's sort of more in keeping
with DC Norms again hiring the right Law
Firm having your lawyers do some of the
dirty work instead of you
um Trump just went right to the source
and said okay well let's just you know
grand jury wants these documents I don't
want to give it to him let's have a
conspiracy to make sure that they don't
get them
um I'm not I I don't feel like I'm in a
position to to really have an
intelligent opinion about whether Donald
Trump's Behavior was or wasn't worse
than Hillary Clinton's I will say this
he was stupider Hillary knew that she
was in the circle of you know of of
trust so to speak in that Circle of
special treatment
um and that she could get away with it
Donald Trump should have known
absolutely that whether it's fair or
unfair he was no longer in the circle uh
you know of of trust and he no longer
had uh the kind of all access free pass
that the clintons possess I think this
is really important because this gets to
not only the question about Trump's
Behavior but also I think a Sinking
Feeling among an increasing number of
Americans what you're describing is
politics particularly in DC and
everything that has come out of you know
Washington realistically over the past
50 years but out of presidencies and you
can you can look at people like uh you
know Bill Clinton and the way that he
acted behind the scenes George Bush in
plain view and the way that we you know
got into things like the Iraq war or the
way we paid for the war we're in the
fourth Act of five acts maybe maybe it's
a four-act play of the degradation of
the way that the government works and in
plain view and this is both the blessing
and the curse I think of the era of
forced transparency that most came into
focus with Wikileaks and this you know
the stuff that Chelsea Manning leaked
and the things that that um Julian
Assange did and he has you know he has
sacrificed his life effectively for
revealing the way the government does
business which is very much at odds with
the idea that there are rules and that
the people involved in this system are
the ones who are maintaining the rules
when nobody's looking you know they're
the equivalent of medieval craftsmen who
you know put full faces on gargoyles
that were you know in the eaves of Notre
Dame you know that nobody would ever see
they are so dedicated to process and we
know that that's horseshit
um and it is terrifying to see Donald
Trump act like that but I think it's
also important to recognize that we got
a bigger problem here and it's not
simply Donald Trump so I think with
characteristic perspicacity and they can
really put your your finger on on the
the heart of the matter if you've ever
been white water rafting
um that your guide will kind of try to
scout the river and what they're looking
for is is sort of what the currents are
doing and where they should be on the
river and you can tell a lot about
what's underneath the surface of a river
by by what you can see on the surface in
terms of you know boils of water and
Swirls and things I think that's really
a good metaphor for What's Happening
Here we are told that no one is above
the law in this country and that is
aspirational and completely false if
you're a sufficiently high-ranking
politician you are absolutely Above the
Law practically speaking and we we don't
we've never really had a kind of a an
explicit conversation about well just
how far above the law like if Donald
Trump beats somebody to death on the
front you know lawn of the of the White
House while he was President would he
have gotten a free pass for that
probably not
um but but do politicians routinely get
free passes for for messing around uh
with classified documents and and
showing them to people who who don't
have a clearance yeah absolutely they do
so there are two questions we've never
really had an explicit discussion about
is just how far above the law are
high-ranking politicians and I think
that's a function frankly of your you
know your status in the organization and
under what circumstance stances can your
free pass be revoked and I I see Trump
in some ways as essentially kind of The
Oaf at a cotillion you know he's this
awkward guy that doesn't know the
rhythms of DC politics and and he comes
you know blundering in you know he's
gotta he's got his invitation but he's
dressed wrong he doesn't speak right
um he's drinking out of his flask and
he's embarrassing everybody
um because you know there's a way that
you're supposed to take advantage of
that free pass and it's the way that the
clintons do it he's embarrassed The
Establishment by you know taking
advantage of his free pass and not doing
it in the according to the the customary
Norms do you think that is an more an
argument for revoking that free pass
from everyone and saying well moving
forward
presidents are not going to be so far
above the law or is it kind of the
opposite where we say look
Trump could have Declassified this he
could have waved the magic wand and this
wouldn't have been a problem at all so
let's just recognize the political
reality that presidents are kind of
Above the Law and that all has to be
resolved
at The Ballot Box and through the
political process
if we're going to give a political
high-ranking political officials a free
pass for violating certain laws then
that suggests that perhaps those laws
shouldn't be on the books at all and
we'd be better off if we just dialed all
that back whether that's even feasible
in other words you know I've been doing
Criminal Justice Reform for a long time
and what I see is essentially a ratchet
here I'm not saying that you could never
repeal a criminal law but it is
extraordinarily uh unusual and the
giving out of free passes to people
whose job almost not requires but you
know it invites them to to violate some
of these laws it's just the
accommodation that we've reached that
we've got these overbought laws on the
books they're virtually impossible to
repeal but we create a situation where a
certain amount of free passes have to be
handed out just to make sure that the
machine continues to operate if there's
a path out of that morass I don't see it
that was an excerpt from our live stream
talking about the Trump indictment with
the Cato institute's Clark Neely if you
want to see the full conversation go
here and if you want to see a different
excerpt go here and make sure to join us
every Thursday at 1 pm Eastern when
reason Zach weismuller and I talked with
somebody very interesting telling you
something that you need to know